in today's morning rounds one suburban
communities desperate measures to limit
the spread of measles the state of
emergency went into effect overnight in
Rockland County New York it bans
unvaccinated children from most public
places 153 people have been infected by
measles in the county since last October
forty-eight of those infections occurred
this year Niki batiste is in West Nyack
Rockland County with how officials hope
the controversial ban will contain the
disease Nikki good morning good morning
starting today the shopping mall behind
me is one of several public places that
Rockland County will not allow
unvaccinated minors to enter the
outbreak here is concentrated in the
Orthodox Jewish community and the county
is now telling parents either get your
children vaccinated or keep them home my
goal is to have this measles measles
officially eradicated again in 28 2019
Rockland County Executive Edie day says
he is determined to end the worst
measles outbreak in the country his
emergency order went into effect at
midnight
banning unvaccinated children under the
age of 18 from entering public places
including schools shopping malls
restaurants and houses of worship it
does not apply to outdoor spaces is this
more of a scare tactic or are you
expecting to actually prosecute people
we are not expected to prosecute anybody
it is an attention-grabber
I wouldn't call it a scare tactic we're
looking to get people to understand the
severity of what we're facing Rockland
County is facing the state's longest
measles outbreak since the disease was
officially eradicated in 2000 des says
more than a quarter of children 1 to 18
years old in Rockland County are
unvaccinated we are still getting people
infected exposures are still happening
in some cases increasing and we'll
meeting resistance and trying to solve
it measles is highly highly contagious
our dr. Jon LaPook says that about 90%
of people who are not vaccinated will
come down with the measles if they are
exposed to it the kicker is that people
can actually be contagious for about
four days before they come down with the
rash they can be running around spread
to other people without even knowing
they have the measles the disease has
been spreading rapidly nationwide there
are 333 confirmed cases of the measles
across 15 states so far this year nearly
surpassing last year's total already and
just yesterday health officials in
Silicon Valley issued a warning that an
international traveler may have exposed
thousands of people there to the disease
@de says the decision to announce his
County's ban was an easy one the best
interest of the people of Rockland
County is to attack this disease with
every tool at our disposal critic
critics of the van Staden fringes on
civil liberties and could be
unconstitutional it will last for thirty
days or until parents decide to get
their child a measles vaccine which is
at least 93 percent effective any parent
of an unvaccinated child who violates
the ban could face up to a $500 fine or
up to six months in jail
fionna definitely an attention grabber
as he had said this is a really
frustrating story to cover Nicky thank
you